ceos have a reputation of being
douchebags they mistreat their employees
exploit every tax loophole known to
mankind and they aren't scared to put
profits before ethics basically every
single well-known founder has this
reputation including jeff bezos bill
gates and mark zuckerberg even the most
cherished of the bunch like elon musk
display many of these characteristics
i mean 80 to 100 hour weeks are
basically the definition of tesla and
spacex's work cultures
many have argued that though these ceos
have produced tremendous results it
wasn't without sacrificing their
humanity and it often seems like such
results are simply not possible without
being a brutal businessman
but in reality hundreds of ceos defied
this notion with one of the most notable
being southwest ceo gary c kelly
in 2021 gary ranked number four on
gloucester's employee choice list with
an approval rating of 98
gary hasn't dropped the ball on
investors either since he took over
southwest stock has quadrupled at the
peak and let's keep in mind this isn't a
tech company it's an airline company
so here's how gary stayed on the good
side of his employees while growing
southwest and one of the most cutthroat
and low profit industries in the world
taking a look back gary joined southwest
way back in 1986 as a modest controller
not to be confused with a flight
controller by trade gary was an
accountant who graduated from the
university of texas at austin
before joining southwest gary had
actually been working at an auditing
company called arthur young and co
so becoming an accounting controller at
southwest was right up his alley at the
time southwest was a rookie in the
airline business who was simply trying
to get ahead the company had just gone
public a few years ago and each share of
the company was worth less than a dollar
in comparison to today's prices given
the small scale nature of southwest it
wasn't too difficult for gary to work
himself up to cfo by 1989
and this is where he would spend the
majority of his early career it wasn't
until 2001 that gary was promoted to
executive vice president but his next
promotion came rather quickly in 2004 to
ceo
since he became ceo he's embraced a
couple of key fundamental values that
have cemented southwest in the hearts of
its employees and customers starting
with a culture of appreciation in large
companies that employ tens of thousands
of employees the individual impact of
each employee is often lost every
employee is simply a cog in the larger
machine and it often feels like the
dispensable slash replaceable but gary
has made sure to emphasize that this is
not the case
and i don't mean just verbally thinking
or praising employees gary has backed up
his words with clear action throughout
southwest entire history they have never
laid off a single employee not after 9
11 not during the financial crisis and
not even during the pandemic this
doesn't mean that southwest just flew
through these crises though they were
actually extremely challenging and
southwest had to enact several
cost-cutting measures however layoffs
and pay cuts to regular employees were
always a last resort i mean just take a
look at how gary handled the pandemic
when the pandemic rolled around it was
clear that southwest had to make massive
reductions in cost given that air travel
demand literally went to zero overnight
instead of laying off employees though
kerry targeted the other side of the
spectrum employees that were over 55 and
approaching retirement
gary offered pilots over the age of 55
two-thirds of their salaries for five
years or until they were 65 for simply
choosing early retirement on top of this
extremely generous compensation plan
gary also offered up to five years of
company provided health insurance
meanwhile employees who were under 55
but had over 10 years of experience with
southwest were offered one year of
salary and one year of company paid
health insurance given how lucrative
this offer was 17 000 employees or 28 of
their workforce took their buyout which
was quite close to gary's 30 target i
think you'd agree that this was
literally the most generous way
southwest could have reduced the
workforce on top of giving employees a
great send-off gary and all the
executives took a pay cut through the
end of 2021
gary's salary was cut to zero dollars
while the other executive salaries were
slashed by 20 percent gary also needed
regular employees to take a pay cut as
well but he didn't want to impose it
so he promised that employees who took a
10 pay cut would have zero risk of being
full load in 2021 and that their pay
would be restored normal starting in
2022 throughout the entire crisis there
was no force or imposing the approach
was always how do we get through this as
a team
maybe older employees can take early
retirement maybe executives can take a
larger pay cut and maybe employees can
take a smaller pay cut southwest has
approached every crisis with this same
team-like approach which has made the
community extremely strong and that
brings us to gary's second strategy
which is breaking down the executive
barrier
as companies grow larger they often have
a tendency to become bureaucratic and
the key reason for this is little to no
decision making power for everyday
employees at southwest however the
decision-making process is completely
decentralized as we saw with the
pandemic it was up to the employees if
they wanted to take a 10 pay cut and
avoid a furlough or if they wanted to
keep their full salary and deal with the
risk of a potential furlough this
decentralization stretches much further
than just allowing employees to choose
their own futures a great example of
this was when southwest was developing a
new uniform for their employees
pilot and flight attendant uniforms are
extremely important as this is what
customers see on a daily basis and it's
essentially the branding of the entire
company given the weight of this
redesign you would think that southwest
would hire top-tier branding specialists
to guide the process but gary had
something else in mind
gary opened up to redesign opportunity
to all southwest employees every
employee who was interested could
provide suggestions for the new uniform
and the employees with the best
suggestions were assembled into a sort
of review team every two weeks the team
would meet up and guide the redesign
process
similarly a significant amount of
decision-making power is given to
low-level managers and employees
gary believes that these individuals are
the ones that have the best
understanding of the work they do and
that they can make way better decisions
than some executive that spends their
entire day in the office
all of this is based on gary's core idea
that employee satisfaction trumps
everything even including customer
satisfaction the truth is customer
satisfaction is directly linked to
employee satisfaction so if you keep
your employees happy customer
satisfaction will follow this doesn't
mean that gary doesn't care about
customers though if anything he cares
about each individual customer just as
much as he cares about each individual
employee if you've ever taken a
southwest flight you might have noticed
that they don't have business or first
class they only have economy originally
this was because southwest was a budget
airline and premium flyers weren't
interested in the company but today
southwest actively chooses against
adding first and business class
southwest does offer something called a
business select but this doesn't
actually get you a better seat or
service
business select simply allows you to
move up the boarding list and it gives
you some additional member rewards
however you'll be sitting in the same
seat and receiving the same service as
someone with an economy ticket by opting
for no first or business class gary has
been able to prevent an executive
barrier from farming amongst customers
and service
it's no secret that most airlines make
the majority of their profit from
business and first class fliers thanks
to how much margin is built into those
services
however this creates large discrepancy
in how customers are treated which goes
against southwest core principle of
valuing each customer equally customers
who fly southwest generally love this
aspect flight attendants aren't
prioritizing business and first class
members and economy customers are the
center of attention now i'm not saying
it's wrong to prioritize business and
first-class customers given that they're
paying way more
however by simply sticking to economy
customers southwest is able to provide
an extremely consistent and reliable
experience to all customers
and speaking of happy customers we have
gary's third strategy which is not
nickeling and diming customers or
employees
ever since 9 11 and especially after the
2008 financial crisis more and more
american airlines have been charging
additional fees on top of the ticket
price for checked bags
and as more airlines adopt a strategy it
becomes harder to compete against them
because they're able to advertise
cheaper starting prices but the truth is
these cheaper prices are deceptively low
considering that most people are going
to need to check in some luggage
southwest has avoided this by simply
allowing all customers to check in two
bags for no additional cost this has
actually become southwest most famous
marketing slogan and is an integral part
of their brand today
unfortunately southwest can't actually
offer the service for free as it costs
money to transport luggage this leads us
the southwest starting prices to
generally be a bit higher than
competitors but southwest customers can
be confident that the ticket price is
all they'll have to pay there aren't any
hidden or additional fees that they'll
find out about when they arrive at the
airport this policy also extends to
other parts of southwest business for
example they don't charge any change
fees or cancellation fees if you want to
switch from one ticket to another you'll
only have to pay the disparity and take
a price if there is one by not nickeling
and diming customers gary has been able
to largely eliminate customer complaints
in fact southwest only receives about
half a complaint for every 100 000
customers they serve which is by far the
lowest in the airline industry gary also
doesn't nickel and dime his employees
either right before the pandemic started
southwest dispersed 667 million worth of
profits to employees which came out to
roughly 12.2 percent of each employee's
salary 10 percent went towards the
retirement plans and the remain 2.2
percent was dispersed as cash at the end
of the day the secrets behind gary's
crazy employee and customer satisfaction
rates aren't actually all that crazy
all he does is give his employees and
customers the freedom to make their own
decisions treats everyone as equals and
he doesn't nickel and dime anyone you
would think that these principles are
pretty easy to apply
but given how many douchebag ceos there
are this clearly isn't the case
but hey at least we have a couple of
star performers like gary what do you
guys think is the biggest key to gary's
popularity amongst employees comment
that down below
also drop a like if you think all ceo
should learn a thing or two from gary
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one